first it's so ironic to make this the
first question since i just had problems
but how is the view
going in isolation like doing it from
home having these conversations
through technology yeah well you know we
really miss each other of course we miss
uh just sitting next to each other and
being able to
um communicate back and forth um
in real time but we haven't really
missed a beat it's kind of
weird um you know i think these times
are sort of made for what we do which is
just to
exchange views different views opinions
and we're all working from home
but it looks like we're working from the
studio right
we have a really good tech team and
we're all on a group text and
sometimes during the commercial breaks
you know we text each other and we talk
and we can actually see each other
um through uh you know these little
ipads believe it or not and
it feels fine and it's just the safest
way to do it
uh for for our show because uh uh
you know it's it's just where where it
is right now megan just had a baby
um joy um is a fantastic woman of a
certain age you know
uh whoopi had a bout of pneumonia double
pneumonia
last year and so this is the best way to
do it
so that we're all still a family and
really safe
right you know what i miss about you
being in studio i'm going to demonstrate
what you usually do
this oh i know i have my
uh that's my favorite when you do that
sonny you do a little
it's so telling yeah that's my miss
that's my list of you being in studio
yeah so
in terms of this book i mean yeah
reading that forward i mean talking
about
the the backlash you got or the the
fight back you got from abc from
including some stuff in the book
in terms of you know you never being
announced as a co-host
even though you've been there for four
years you didn't have a dressing room on
the same level as other people initially
now that the book is out there what's
the feedback you've gotten from abc
or your co-host at the view you know
it's been remarkable i was really
nervous when i wrote it i knew that it
was a risk
there aren't that many people i think
that that write
books about their current employers and
then still keep their jobs
still you know embraced but
the president of walt disney studios
called me
and said i've read your book um and we
need to do better
i'm sorry about everything you've
experienced and let's recalibrate our
relationship
and i want you to be part of uh the way
forward i got the same type of call
across the board from the president of
abc news
from my executive producers and from not
only my current co-host
but probably from the majority of
co-hosts uh on the view from the past
so it was just this wonderful embrace
um from the abc and disney family that
i've got to tell you i would have never
expected
and it just goes to show you that maybe
it is time for all of us to kind of
stand up and speak
out and ask for um
our value right and our worth and not be
afraid to do that
and um i i've been really
pleasantly surprised at how i perceived
i really have been
yeah speaking of this time like you're
right that you were finalizing it
when george floyd was killed and
throughout your book you talk about
different points like when trayvon
martin was killed how much that had
affected you and reporting on that
samia rice ir garner now that your book
is coming out during this time when
black lives matter is such part of the
national conversation where do you think
your book
fits into that conversation well it's
been received
um in in such an incredible way uh
i've gotten you know calls
and emails and letters uh from so many
people saying
you know thank you for giving voice to
this and for giving us some of the
language to deal with it
so certainly it is timely and i do feel
that
that while i was born uh in the middle
of the civil rights struggle
um that this is now a continuation of
that movement
it's not just a moment i i see a
movement and what i'm
really encouraged by is that i'm seeing
not a movement just with the within the
african-american community i mean i'm
seeing this ally ship
that i have not seen um previously and
i'm seeing it not only in
the united states it's all over the
world i mean you see it in canada
you see it
you see in japan you see it in hong kong
it has been a worldwide movement
and that is very very different and you
know my book is in spanish and in
english
justice sotomayor the supreme court
insisted that i do that
and so i did that and i've received the
same type of feedback from spanish
language readers
that they are um involved in the black
lives matter movement
and um they they want to be involved so
this is this is a different time and i'm
just happy that
um my book is being received as as
not a guide but as um an example
of where we can go so that that's been
wonderful
yeah it absolutely is and so much of it
is about your own personal identity in
terms of a black woman
in terms of a puerto rican woman and
your original name i'm going to try to
say
it i want to i have an irish scottish
background but ah
pretty good pretty good okay pretty good
yeah i know you said
nancy grace was the one that told you to
change it like early in your career
how do you think your career would be
different your tv career would be
different
if you kept your birth name you know i
think it would have been different
i do um and it pains me to say that
um because it is a difficult name to
pronounce right it's asuncion
and i feel like i gave up a bit of my
identity because i'm named after my
grandmother's sister and my grandmother
never really forgave me for that
and it's been an identity issue with my
career because spanish is my first
language i speak spanish
i've done you know cnn and espanol when
i worked there
and now people kind of wonder well do
you speak spanish are you latina what is
your background and by giving up that
that name i almost gave up my connection
to my
identity i americanized my name
but people my career took off when i
changed my name
it did people remembered me and that's
exactly what nancy said she said
at a break on court tv can i say
something to you
they can't pronounce it they can't
remember it and she sort of just
explained to me that she felt that i had
a future
in american television but that my name
would be a roadblock
and i changed it
um and i did see a difference so it's
unfortunate
but it's something that i would not
advise someone to do today
because i think we have to really
embrace who we are and we have to
encourage that kind of diversity
and inclusion not do what i did which
was just
you know try to get along um because i
do think representation matters
yeah no absolutely and one of the things
i loved about the book i found really
interesting was
your friendships with people within the
media world like i mean you just spoke
about nancy a little bit
i found your conversations that you've
had on a vero really fascinating
and your relationship with megan kelly
was really interesting too that you
that all of these women that you
appreciate them but you've had some
difficult
conversations along the way like how do
you value those
relationships like especially megyn
kelly have a very weird you know history
now with megan like how do you
value those relationships and those
experiences you know i think you learn
um a lot from people who think
differently
um i i do i learn a lot from failure i
learn more from failure than success
um and i like that free exchange of
ideas maybe it's the lawyer in me
right like you know freedom of
expression and ideas
and um i found megan um
really interesting because she when we
worked together at fox she was whip
smart
very prepared and she made me better on
television because i knew i had to be
very prepared now the megan that i see
today
um is not the megan that i knew then the
things that she's saying
um the thing you know these alleged
views
um i don't believe it quite frankly i
think it's theater
um because it's so far from from what i
i know
um and if that is truly who she is i'm
disappointed
um but but but i can say i still value
the exchange of ideas and i still value
that she
made me better because she was so
competitive
because she was quite frankly really
good at television
she was really good and there's
something to be said
about that something to be said about um
someone
who is good at what they do and makes
you better
yeah and i know you said the most
difficult chapter to write was
the chapter on motherhood and
infertility why was it the most
difficult chapter to write and have your
kids read the book
oh that's a great question my best
friend
uh asked me yesterday she she just read
the book
um and she said she cried during that
chapter
chapter seven motherhood um and even
though she lived through it with me
she uh didn't realize how painful of the
time it was for me and that's why it's
so hard
um and i when i read the audio narrated
the audiobook i cried
um and sobbed afterwards as did the
director for the audio book um
my son and my daughter neither of them
has read the chapter
um and neither of them knew that um
what we had gone through to have them i
did have the discussion with them
when uh the book was going to come out
because i wanted them to hear it from me
um and they were pretty quiet uh but
my daughter said wow you really wanted
to have us
and i said yeah we really did so that
was a wonderful
um reaction and acceptance of it but
i think that people don't talk about
infertility enough
um for some reason it's this um there's
a stigma and people feel ashamed of it
and that's why even though it was so
painful for me to relive
because you do relive things when you're
writing a memoir i thought
wow i've got to talk about it and it's
one of the chapters that
um i've received i think probably
thousands
of um notes about from
women that are struggling with
infertility so
that makes me that makes me um happy
to know that it's helpful yeah you made
the right choice yeah
i know we're running late but so i just
have one more question that's on my cord
that we're running late but yeah
i want to ask you with this um one quote
that you have in the book it says it's
talking about the view
that you say that's the power of this
platform that's the power of having a
seat here
that's the power of being in the room
i'm curious for
for you whether it's this book whether
it's the view
what do you bring or what do you want to
bring what do you want to continue to
bring
to the room hmm that's a great question
you know
i really believe that you can't live a
perfect day without doing something for
someone who can't repay you
and you can't
do that without being in a position
to help other people um being in the
room
where things happen means everything
and for me when i finally got into those
rooms
and it's taken a long time i've been a
lawyer for over 25 years
i'm aging myself
i've been in media now over 15 years
i decided that i was going to use my
voice
to give voice to those that just don't
have that kind of platform to give
representation for those
that don't have representation and if
that
gives hope to a little girl or a little
boy that looks like me
if that gives hope to someone who is
thinking
gosh thankfully someone is sticking up
for me
or giving my view um then i've done what
i set out to do
right i've combined my passion with my
purpose um
and i wish that for everyone i i really
really do because
i don't wake up in the morning and feel
like i'm going to work
i wake up in the morning and i feel like
wow i can't wait to
do this and it that's
i wish that kind of feeling for everyone
you